you have to have some sense of
dissatisfaction from the world if you
wake up and you're happy happy and
everything is great then you probably
are just gonna
go around your business and and
everything continues as is but you have
to have some sort of dissatisfaction you
have to see on one hand the problem
where other people don't but you also
have to see an opportunity so for me
building stuff is identifying some sort
of
change that is possible in the world and
then going about and articulating that
vision
getting a team around it building in my
case technology around it you could do
that in art you could do that in cooking
you could do that in writing you could
do that in many different ways
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders if software
is eating the world then ai is devouring
it meet shai david the co-founder
chairman and ceo of retrain ai
dr shai david is a serial entrepreneur
known for previously co-founding the
video enterprise unicorn kaltura where
he served as cto cro and general manager
of media and telecom from inception to
exponential growth prior to kaltura shai
was a co-founder in destinator
technologies a leader in mobile gps
navigation software shai founded retrain
ai to address what he finds as one of
the biggest challenges of the workforce
today the skills gap cheyenne his team
created a platform that analyzes jobs
occupations and skills and recommends
personalized training pathways to bridge
the skills gap
hi david welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you
i'm fantastic uh calling in from london
today michael good to be here
so good to have you i i'm just gonna
enjoy sitting back in these 20 minutes
and picking your brain
over your incredible journey and the
incredible things that you're doing
today is co-founder ceo and chairman of
retrain ai
but your your background is just is just
incredible from being a
previously uh you know co-founder and
director of kaltura and congratulations
on on the public offering fellow ideal
law school
a phd in information systems from
cornell
masters of arts in in new york
university so many incredible things
that you've done that there i we can
spend now two hours with my questions
but i know your time is so valuable so
i'd love to focus on retrain ai and and
understand how throughout all of your
experience you've sort of converged on
on your own convictions of what's
happening in today's world the role of
ai with with jobs and occupations and
and how you're building retrain ai to
change the landscape so right before we
do that tell me a little bit about
yourself and about your personality
because i'm always intrigued by the
personality of the people that are doing
incredible things like you've done
fantastic so again great to be here
michael and and happy to chat about any
of these things um
my background was always kind of on the
verge between uh
scholarship and
entrepreneurship and i built and had
built a few big companies last week
project was cultura which just went
public a few weeks ago
because it was an exciting journey kind
of started my living room and together
with three amazing co-founders uh one
michael and iran
uh we built a big company um and anybody
interested could go look at kltr
yeah on the nasdaq but we built that
business from from really from the
ground up to incredible thousand
customers and hundreds of millions of
dollars in sales
so pretty exciting um
in terms of personality i'm a builder i
like to build stuff so cultural was the
last big thing before the run and i
built another company called the
destinator which was a gps navigation
company before there a couple other
startups and now my new baby is
retrained together with two other
co-founders avi and isabel
and we're building what i believe is
going to be a very meaningful platform
that is aiming to solve the skills gap
and i'm happy to tell you kind of more
about it but it's all about putting
technology to good use
and
letting machines do the hard work so
that humans can fulfill their full
potential
i i love that mission statement right
before we get to to what that actually
means what what do you mean by builder
what does it mean for you
to call yourself a builder how does that
come about you know in the in the
everyday things that are not necessarily
you know building companies because
you're treating it as a personality
trait and a characteristic
yeah i think that
you know there's a lot of creativity
of
the process of taking an idea and making
it real
it's about
creating a vision and i think that
that's probably true for every
entrepreneur but you have to have some
sense of dissatisfaction from the world
if you wake up and you're happy happy
and everything is great then you're
probably are just gonna go around your
business and and everything continues as
is but you have to have some sort of
dissatisfaction you have to see on one
hand the problem
where other people don't but you also
have to see an opportunity so for me
building stuff is identifying some sort
of the
change that is possible in the world and
then going about and articulating that
vision
getting a team around it building in my
case technology around it you could do
that in art you could do that in cooking
you could do that in writing you could
do that in many different ways
the way that i've been expressing the
capacity to build is a building
technology and particularly software
systems in the last two decades
a brief history of the way that ai is
shaping the way we think about jobs and
people's roles because i think that that
your perspective on this is going to be
critical to our understanding of how
you're thinking through
the role of retrain ai as an as a part
of this new society that we're building
with us
yes so so i think there's a
to get the background we have to
understand that tsunami is coming to the
world of work and that tsunami to bring
you back to your high school physics
about to kind of
multiple waves converging what's
creating this tsunami of three three
major waves one is that there's a
dramatic and dynamic shift
in skills demand the nature of work is
changing
what used to be a role definition of a
teacher where you had to write with
white chalk on blackboard is changing
now teachers need to use zoom to work in
a warehouse you needed to lift boxes and
now you probably need to operate a robot
to
a working supply chain you need to do
certain things and now with the
introduction of
automation you need to do other things
to work in transportation mean driving a
lorry and now you probably need to
operate a drone and of course i'm
exaggerating because none of these
things are happening overnight but
the adoption of automation
the adoption of remote work the adoption
of transition and digital transformation
is changing what work is
that's wave number one wave number two
is there's a very significant
constriction in skill supply and we all
or maybe not all of us but most of us
intuitively we know that there are
programmers that are missing and maybe
pilots that are missing and maybe nurses
that are missing millions of people are
missing there's not enough talent around
the world what people don't know this is
also true for mid-skill and sometimes
even for low-skilled labor there's a
worldwide shortage of labor and how
could that be how could we have on one
hand all these headlines about huge
unemployment on one hand and a
consistent complaint by ceos and
business land managers is not enough
talent to go around the answer is the
skills gap the people that are ready to
work do not necessarily have the skills
to be able to actually do the work
and so that's wave number two and wave
number three is that in most situations
where there's a mismatch between demand
and supply there's two approaches to
solve it either you create a marketplace
or you have a systems approach when you
can create that match
between those but in the case of hr both
of those systems are failing there is no
good global marketplace for talent on
one hand and the systems that are
designed to manage hr for the most part
are quite outdated the human capital
management systems in most organizations
are quite outdated
these three waves together create this
tsunami where on one hand
we're seeing this very significant shift
in demand on the other hand a limited
supply on the on the kind of third
aspect lack of good systems and the
outcome is a dramatic limitation
company's capability to grow on one hand
and a dramatic mismatch in the talent
pool where unemployment
is the symptom unemployability is the
problem more and more people just cannot
join the workforce so companies are not
getting enough talent and people can't
find work and this is the problem that
we aim to solve because we believe
that in such a data rich but information
poor area ai which is no more and more
no less than the capability to identify
patterns and data can serve a
significant role in in solving that
skills gap
now as you're thinking through what
technologies you can build as a
technology company and you're
you're looking at a very general problem
you know across the world how are you
even beginning to think through with
your team what kind of solutions
are going to be to become enablers of
this positive change
so too i've said two things about that
first is we think that this is a data
science problems right we're all data
data geeks and and data queens i would
say
and we think that
there's a very significant data science
problem here and the first order of
business is to create a taxonomy
and an ontology that could describe the
world of jobs the world of people and
the world of training pathways
the logical jump here is that
the skills gap problem is no more and no
less
than a problem of understanding what do
employers actually need what are the
skills that are relevant in today's
workforce on one hand and where are the
jobs that could use those skills
right on one hand
on the other hand what could the people
do what do they want to do what are they
capable of doing what did they learn
how to do and now we can start creating
those matches in some cases it could be
a direct match and maybe we can
put somebody to work in an area where
they didn't think they necessarily had
the skills or the talent but in other
cases it wouldn't be a direct match and
then we need to be able to map the
training pathways
in the same taxonomy to say
you're at point a you need to be at
point b and here's a pathway a different
way to think about all this think about
the creating the google maps or creating
the ways of the labor market we're
creating the map of occupational
opportunity
we're able to map individuals on that
map we're able to charge the courses of
where individuals need to be and want to
be and potentially we can even show you
where the traffic jams are by being able
to create a layer prediction and
optimization
to be able to show how you get from
point a to point b c and d
so are you effectively redefining you
know job titles and descriptions as we
know them because from what i understood
from you before part of the mismatch is
the fact that you know over generalized
titles don't necessarily fit a specific
person but it could be that what the
company actually needs are exactly what
this person may have but they may lack
some other skills that would
traditionally be defined within the role
that this company is sort of looking for
for a lack of a better term for what
they're looking for right
that's that's exactly that's exactly
right and there's a big trend in hr tech
today which we are part of we didn't
define that but there's a move away from
job title job description into a skills
framework
right
there's a second move from skills
framework into career pathways and one
of the things that happens because of
this tsunami i was describing earlier is
that the changes
that are required both on an individual
and organizational level are so rapid
that existing systems just can't keep up
so people historically have been hiring
against job title that no longer works
when the job title becomes
empty because it changes right i gave an
example earlier of teachers and
warehouse employees but
think about examples from pretty much
every domain the title might stay the
same
but the actual content of that job is
changing very rapidly so we're helping
organizations move into a skills
framework and a typical question that we
ask is part of our
sales process for example we would come
to a ceo or a business line manager or a
chro
and ask him um listen michael do you
have a bank account and you would say of
course i have a bank account why do you
have a bank account because i have this
resource it's called money
and i'm attached to my money and i want
to see it i want to secure it i want to
visualize it i want to make it grow but
you also have another another type of
resource you have skills
right and you have organization skills
or you have individual skills in the
case of an individual how do you manage
your skills portfolio oh i do that with
sticky notes on the fridge in the
cafeteria or or maybe i do that with
excel well that doesn't cut it if you're
a large employer you're a government
organization or if you're an individual
that's looking to define your career
pathway managing your skills portfolio
on sticky notes in the fridge
is just not going to cut it so think
about our system as the partner of that
financial system to help you manage what
is predominantly your most
significant research which is your
skills portfolio and kind of skills
wallet
so you've already had vast experience in
building large large businesses starting
from you know the living room all the
way to to an ipo
as you're building this technology with
this conviction of okay this is what the
world actually needs this is how you
know a healthy job market should operate
what what is sort of your thinking
strategy you know in in you know 30 000
from the air in in scaling this how do
we get this to be a marketplace where we
have you know potentially most employers
and most future employees leveraging
this new definition of skill based
positions
so i think
i think there are multiple avenues to
market i think on one hand there's a
government aspect here and working with
organizations around the world whose job
it is to get people into jobs every
single country around the world has
employment services has a department of
labor the chambers of commerce has
professional associations there are a
lot of people that wake up in the
morning and their job is to train the
workforce of the future
and to make sure that that workforce has
the right skills and then to help them
find a job so one hand we have aspects
of collaborating with government
organizations and ngos and other
ecosystem partners whose job it is to
basically train people and helping find
jobs on one hand but on the other hand
and i think that's probably an even
bigger commercial opportunity
is to work with employers as they are
changing right the objective is not only
to help people that are out of the job
markets to get back into the job market
but to actually work with employers that
are undergoing rapid transformation
before they actually let go of the
workforce
think about a bank that is moving from
physical branches into e-commerce and
mobile banking for example right
they have a lot of people working in
branches
and
in contrast to kind of the capitalist
the
pig metaphors that you might read in the
papers when we talk with business
leaders they do not have an aspiration
to just fire everybody and start fresh
it's true in the headlines in the paper
that's not the reality the reality is
that most leaders they understand that
the most valuable asset that they have
is the people
they are very sorry for every person
that they need to go but sometimes they
just don't know how to keep the talent
so we're working with say big banks or
big retailers that are moving from
physical stores to e-commerce we're
moving from
people that are moving from
say
print publishing to digital publishing
all these industries that are being
transformed
we want to work with the large employers
and when i think about scale
the goal that we set for the company is
to have 10 million people find
meaningful employments in the first five
years
we've been working for about a year now
so we have four years left to achieve
that mission and we're kind of well
underway
but we want to work with the world's
largest employers to make a really big
impact and we've been contacted by
organizations the world over
that are saying to us listen we want to
preserve our talent we want to help our
people upskill we want to gain new
skills for our employees and for our
organization as well how do we do it
this is where the ai comes in what we've
developed is a system that understands
any language it understands english it
understands hebrew it understands
spanish then it understands any language
and it could read
job descriptions it could read cvs it
could rent linkedin profiles it could
read water that just understands
the language and we've trained the ai
models and language from the labor
market so that you can start creating
those matches and starts helping the
organizations understand
what are their own needs how does their
own talent pool match against those
needs and how do they solve the skills
gap by either
being able to retrain internal talent or
prioritize external hiring um so that
they could um
solve that skills gap organizationally
die i love it so much you know one of
the things that i'm thinking about as
you're as you're talking about it you
know i'm thinking about how you know
sometimes we can be sort of in our own
bubble and we're seeing the tech
ecosystem and we're seeing the way that
you know jobs are you know people get
jobs here and we we almost forget that
you know the majority of the world the
vast majority of the world it doesn't
operate this way and and and the world
is changing and and
job security is changing and
and i just love it when entrepreneurs
take technology understand how different
people interact and how the real world
works outside of our own tech scene and
and build technology that can scale to
ridiculous amounts and and i'm so
hopeful to reach that 10 million
goal within five years and that's
personally where i gain my inspiration
and this is exactly why i'm doing this
show so so really thank you for these 20
minutes i have a few more questions for
you cheyenne going back a little bit to
your personality which also intrigues me
and i want you to take me back to your
to your childhood you mentioned that you
know you've always been a builder you're
always curious always um you know a
computer a computer kid
what really sparked your curiosity you
know when it all started even back in
elementary middle school what really
fascinated you
yeah i did part of my elementary school
actually in the valley in in palo alto
and um i got exposed to those early days
of computing um originally i didn't even
like the first personal computers that i
had wasn't personal at all it was a
public ti 99 computer in palo alto as a
public library where you would get one
hour a week so you had to write your
code on paper
get your one hour type it as fast as you
can
hope that the program runs and then your
time was up
what inspired me then was this idea that
it was the early days of computing and
the capacity of machines to go get the
hard
work done for the people so that the
people could
do the more interesting stuff
and inspiring for me is to think about
human potential
and to think about how machines can help
humans achieve that potential and i
believe that particularly on the
on the skills issue every person has
huge potential our job
as entrepreneurs as technologies and as
builders is to make sure that the
machines work for the people and not
vice versa
many of the ai
companies particularly in the valley are
about taking jobs away from people and
we think that that same technology
that's creating the disruption
could actually help achieve human
potential in much greater way
i love it and if you look today at what
you do whether it's retrain ai or or
leading a new company where do you drive
your day-to-day inspiration from
i think it's from the capacity to really
help a lot of people and i think that
you're absolutely right to point out
that sometimes we live in a bubble
especially in tech
we all had a great year during covet
because business tech businesses were
doing great and stock portfolios were
doing great and all of us are ordering
on
takeout and working at home and life is
good but for many of the other people
that wasn't the case right it was a very
tough year and many people lost their
jobs many people lost their lives
so what inspires me is the capacity to
put technology to good use
in the hands of a lot of people that
might not otherwise benefit
and to make technology consumable
by large enterprises and by individuals
and to make sure that the machines work
for us and vice versa
i love it and if i were to ask any of
your co-founders either now or from
kaltura before
what are what are a few words that
represent shai david and i'll start with
builder but i want you to add a few more
yeah i would say that getting things
done is probably one of them
but uh but i think that at the
aspiration at the higher level i would
say mind body and spirit it's all about
embodied experience it's not just about
building stuff but it's about building
things in the real world
that solve real problems and that really
catered to the human spirit
die thank you very very much
this was inspiring and this episode is a
perfect example of why i i love doing
this show so thank you very much for
your time i know how busy you are and
best of luck and stay safe and stay
healthy
fantastic let's uh stay positive and
test negative
thank you for having me